hello welcome back to another beginner
tutorial on C++ this is gonna be the
last one of this series I think it's
getting a little played out at this
point and really the last thing I want
to talk about is just sort of moving
forward with your classes so I've gone
back to our little tutorial calculator
thing that we did on episode 5 and going
forward and I'm just gonna open it up
and visual studio code here and
basically what I want to go over and
this is in this episode is it's just
getting a little more advanced with your
classes and building them out to make
them a little more long-term usable now
there's there's so much you can do with
classes that it's it's sort of
overwhelming and there's no way I'm
gonna cover it all in just a couple
toriel's but I at least wanted to get
into talking about overloading operators
and storing your data within your class
so so currently we have a let's say
let's look at our main currently we have
a little thingamajigger that just when
we update this class is moving forward
so currently we instantiate our little
calculator class that we made and we
just run it until the user wants to quit
but we don't really do anything with the
results they just kind of sit there so
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna show you
how to store the results and how to
maybe overload some operators to to add
those parts of it together and I'm not
sure how complicated I'm going to get
with it real quick here the over
loadable operators on little copy-paste
here so overloading operators
and I know that might be a vague term to
test some of you out there that are new
let's do this so we can do a block but
basically what you can do is you can
take all these little keywords and you
can put them in your class so that when
you use these operators on your class it
does special stuff that you define
specifically for your class like we can
overload the plus so that when we use it
on our class it does some special
operation and same with all these others
because if you just try to add two if
you instantiate two calculators and you
try to add them together C++ is gonna
have an error and the compilers just
going to be really confused but if you
have it overloaded then you can define
what that plus does to your calculator
class for example now this isn't exactly
the best class to do this on to be
honest so I'm probably only gonna pick a
few of them but I just want to show you
that this works so let me make sure I'm
doing this syntax right before I dive
right in and okay so let's say we want
to not only overload operators but we
also want to store the data of stuff
we've just anything we've ran so let's
make a private storage and we'll do a
vector of past entries basically or past
results and these could be well we're
only working with floats here so we're
just gonna just keep it floats our float
past results however you want to do your
syntax I'll just do it
camel cased so anytime we do an
operation will just add to this vector
and store all all our past results that
way we can have access to them later
because currently once you want you to
run through a calculation it's it prints
out and then it's gone so in theory in a
class you often want to save the stuff
it's doing that way you can add in
things like undo and redo and save and
restore all that stuff and you can kind
of go from there and use your
imagination
but of course we're going to need to
include vector for this to be happy and
see the vector so now when we do it this
run main go into it here and now when we
get to the very end and we spit out the
result we could also do a push back of
our result and we're only storing the
number we could build a little structure
to store even more like what we what
operation we did it and all that but we
don't want to get that complicated
because it was a start getting confusing
but basically we're gonna do our four
operations and we're going to save our
results and then we'll over load
something and have it spit out our
results using that overload so you can
at least see the syntax of an overload
overloaded operator I'm using overload
sort of generically cuz you're gonna
overload any function by just I don't
like we said in the like I said in the
overload functions tutorial but these
operators is what I've talked about in
this episode when I say overload I mean
really mean overload operators okay so
let's say they do this they do an ADD
will want to do something like
what was that previous or past results
past results I push back and will do
whatever that result was first number
plus second number no we probably
honestly want to store this in a
variable to push back but we can do it
in place too and what this will do is
it'll go ahead and add these together
create a new variable that we don't even
see and then push that back so it'll
kind of do it all magically but a better
way to honestly do this might be
something like results go ahead and put
the result here and it might be you know
it might be the same efficient
efficiency wise but it depends on your
compiler some compilers will do more
optimizations and others and speaking of
we can tell our compiler to optimize by
putting in a flag I believe it's capital
o and then the number two is for
optimization level two and that will try
to improve our code to make it run a
little faster there's you can do other
optimization levels as well and I
encourage you to read more about those
online if you're curious about what that
does but basically it just goes through
your program tries to make it run a
little faster by optimizing some things
like it could be stuff like this and it
might just see a better way of doing
this and decide to optimize it and it
can optimize some of your loops and
stuff like that so just FYI I'll go
ahead and make the result for this one
but for the rest of these I'm just gonna
do it the fast way of just taking this
and pasting it over and over but this
time when you use first this first
number and second number and that way I
can just do a quick copy paste job here
that's the subtract one
this is the multiply one and this is the
divide one I'm good and clean up my
syntax
I was control a control K control F to
do that syntax clean thing with visual
studio code control a control ok control
F a KF almost afk and now what will
happen is anytime we run a calculation
it's just gonna add to that vector with
whatever the past result is so it'll
continue to grow as the program goes
goes on we do more calculations but we
don't have any way of viewing this
they're private there's nothing we can
do it so we could make a quick little
function like see past results as a way
of accessing it and we can have this
function since it's public we can call
it of course we need to actually put it
within our you know actually this could
be private because you could only be
called through our run function so that
would be that would be fine and we just
need to throw the option somewhere in
here so maybe we do 5 to see past
results and we'll have to increase this
of course to allow for more choices and
I think we got an update or a little
choice thing - I'll just put a see past
option in there into our enum so
hopefully this is a good example of how
you can kind of extend your class in two
different ways depending on what you
ultimately want to do with it and yeah
yeah like I said earlier the options are
just so large and endless that there's
just no way any tutorials ever gonna
cover it you just kind of have to put
the concepts together and get creative
with what your goal is and often just
having that goal is is the hardest part
so let's put a new case in here and
we're gonna call this one
what was it seek past and so I think
what we'll do here is we'll just call
see past results keep it simple here now
we could build the whole functionality
of the see past results right here and
of course we want to break so that it
doesn't flow through and go to this
default if you don't have these breaks
in case you don't know it'll just keep
going so like if I didn't have this
break here for example any time I didn't
add it would finish this and then go to
subtract and you would probably just be
really confused so if that ever happens
in your switch statements it's because
you forgot a break so that's that can be
important and there can be times when
you want it to flow through in certain
logical cases depending on what you're
doing but in general you want a break
there so we've got that seep past
results we do need to build this
function and basically we're just going
to do it down here of course we got to
tell our little object file here that
this is part of the calculator class by
scoping it that way and we'll just loop
through and with vectors you can do this
for auto and you can call it anything
I'll call it or for result and past
results and that'll loop through the
entirety of past results and every
element will be this r4 result so every
element is going to be a float of course
so we can do something with this our
we'll just do a plain old see out of it
and and we'll just put them with commas
in between I say I believe that'll be
fine let's do it this way
and that should be fine our very last
ones gonna have a comma on it so that's
gonna look a little weird so we could do
something to say like if we're on the
last one don't add the comma but I'm not
gonna worry about that and yeah there we
go
so let's go ahead and run this oh yeah
maybe we want a case here because what
if there are no results so we'll say if
past results is a vector file past
results is a vector so we can use any of
the vector stuff and we can check if
empty so if it's empty this will be true
and it'll go into this if statement and
we can say something like no results yet
and then of course it's gonna flow
through and hit this for but we don't
need it to if it's empty so we'll just
hit a return right here which will
return from this function not a huge
deal because this is empty anyway it
won't do anything if past results is
empty it won't even go into the loop but
a small optimization that we can make so
let's let's do a make run here to
rebuild and run it Oh what am I doing
wrong here do I not have that built up
no i don't i only have default okay so
let's just do make and it looks like it
has some a case error that it's not
happy about what is this let's take a
look here and remember function void
calculator run error jump to label
subtract crosses initial ation tradition
realization for flow results okay when
it
oh I see okay so you can't instantiate
variables within these cases unless you
have them scoped like so so you got to
create a scope if you want to
instantiate a variable so that should
take care of it that's a good little
lesson to know in a very common error
right there so now you can see it
compiles so yeah because I'm declaring a
new float in here it just doesn't it
doesn't like it and you'll see this sort
of error all right so now it compiles a
better solution would probably be to do
it like I did the rest of them but meh
so let's go ahead and hit five to see
past results confirm that okay we got no
results yet so yes let's do another
we'll just do an ADD I'll add five plus
six let's do another and we'll take five
past results
there's our five let's do a few more
real quick I'm just gonna press some
buttons would you oh I hit I didn't okay
let's rebuild I don't really need to
rebuild let's do one then I'll hit two
numbers yes to press two random numbers
yes three press some random numbers yes
four press some random numbers and then
we'll yes and hit five to see past
results and there's our results looks
let's see what we've got here we got a
seven this number in this number which
has an e plus six so it's kind of hard
to read it's a giant number and then we
have this number and then it's asking us
if we want to do another calculation and
it kind of looks a little odd there we
could format it better but it is saving
properly and we could add new more
methods to
to clear our results to do special
things with them but that's not really
that important for us right now I mean
ideally you'd want to be able to clear
them somehow so maybe we should add more
options to make this more extendable but
this is really just a sample so I'm not
gonna get into all that so what I think
the the best one to overload here in our
case is going to be this output one and
we can just use that instead of see past
results so if we do a see out and then
put our calculator class we just try to
see out our calculator it will spit out
all our past results so that way I can
show you a an overloaded operator and
they are all pretty much the same so
once you've done one the rest are just
the same syntax and let's see here we we
do need to return the class so we'll do
a calculator and we'll do an operator
and then get two of these brackets and
then parentheses for the variables it
takes this one's not gonna take well
this one's gonna take our calculator so
let's let's do a calculator here and you
do have to do it by reference and give
it any sort of name I'll just call it
calc you can spell it right there we go
so that declares it and now we want to
actually build it cuz that's just an AR
header and we'll build it way at the
bottom here well I thought I copied it
guess I didn't here we go
copy yeah we'll give it some things that
it does of course we need to scope it to
calculator otherwise it's not going to
work if I'm making any errors here I
will correct them and get it to compile
at the end
so I think this is okay though I feel
like maybe this has to be returned by
rhythms I don't remember off the top of
my head but basically we'll just do the
exact same thing we do here now go ahead
and paste that and we'll go up to this
option of see past results and we'll
just do I'll just do this
I think star this or just this yeah that
should work now I haven't talked about
this as a keyword but when you use the
word this and in any of your classes
like in your class definitions it it
makes it talk about the captain this
class that you're currently working with
so as you're in the class it's gonna
refer to the original object and that
should work to refer back to this
original object and spit this out and
that that's a really awkward thing to be
perfectly honest to do in this sort of
scenario but it works because this
operator wants a reference to this class
and that's exactly what this is more
likely you would see this sort of
scenario that's something like this
since we've instantiated it up here it
would be more like someone would do
something like that but I think we're
gonna do a yeah reference to it in that
case so when we exit before we exit our
program we'll get we'll see our results
again if I have this here let me just
make sure yep it's public all right and
we'll go ahead and run it again me exit
this current one do a build doesn't like
something about return oh okay
returning statement with no value and
function calculator okay another thing I
missed about overloading this needs to
return a reference to the same class
that way you can chain them just like we
can chain
these here the way it does that is every
time it does it returns reference back
to a stream so the same case with this
we need to return a reference back to
the stream that way it can be chained
properly like the other ones and we can
that way we can do stuff like this now
that's sort of advanced but that's
that's the reason it needs a return so
in it oh I guess we do it here return
make sure I get this right here so one
reference Rd reference know it seems
happy with that okay
and if it gets the end up doing this for
loop we need to return down here to okay
well let's see if that's happy seems to
work okay let's give it a run let's do
an ad real quick 45 + 55 let's do
another see past results here and it
looks like it is spitting out some
really odd thing now what this is you
just tell by the 0x it's it's a hex
value and a hex value no we saw from the
last episode that a pointer is 8 bytes
of memory and this is exactly 8 bytes 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 so what we can deduce here
is that this is a pointer to a piece of
memory and that's what we're getting
pretty interesting right and
so we can deduce the here that this our
that it's spitting now is a reference to
memory let me see something here so if
we let's see let me just try this and
see what happens
this is sometimes how it just goes with
programming is you've got to do a few
tests do some more reading and check
your scenarios ok that's not the problem
it's having so it's something with the
way I'm overloading this maybe do I need
to I think I need to change what this is
returning I feel like I'm doing this
slightly wrong overloading operator
equals and C++ so a very specific Google
about your case will often find you a
nice article on exactly what you're
doing there's a lot of information out
there so that's very nice so I just did
a goo of it and that's actually a really
important thing to know about
programming to is just don't be afraid
to Google the exact problem you have
chances are you will find an answer and
that's what I'm doing now
oops I'm looking at a Java one that's no
good
no it's not Java 1 it's just an article
that's not very clear another article
it's not very clear ok ok I found I
found what is probably gonna be our best
answer here ok you have something need
to make it that big so you this is a
class this is kind of just a sample a
returning a reference to calculator here
and they are making this Const which is
probably a good idea and when they're
doing a return it's their returning star
this so we probably need to do that
because we are returning what appears to
be just a pointer and this is D
referencing a pointer here when you do
start this so star this makes a lot more
sense in this case because we want to
dereference star this and this should be
a reference here and this might be a lot
to wrap your head around I haven't
really talked about referencing but
basically when you reference a variable
it looks at the the pointer to it or
them with the memory location and when
you dereference it it goes the reverse
direction those get confusing pretty
fast sometimes but when in doubt just
look it up do a careful analysis and
you'll usually figure it out and take
note of what works and why and you
should be able to figure them out for
too long so let's do another build after
making those changes run it one last
time and hopefully we right add 1 plus 2
sure let's see the results and we're
still getting some log results well
I'm going to give up so I don't feel
like messing with it anymore if you can
figure this out leave a comment and I
will give you a high five I'm sure it's
something I could figure out eventually
but in particular since this is a
program I'm actually going to use I
don't really care anymore at the moment
and you know sometimes that's just the
case with programming as you're doing
something that doesn't matter
and well I don't mean to discourage
anyone but yeah it's probably something
really simple and I got other stuff to
do so moving on thank you for watching
this last tutorial yeah if you know what
this problem is and want to leave in the
comments bonus points to you thanks
again for watching and in any of the
support any and all the support you guys
give me here I will leave links down
below to some of my other stuff the
patreon I just opened and if you want to
see more tutorials and maybe more
specific stuff I'll try to do some in
the future but just let me know because
beyond the basics of C++ once you know
how to do all this basic stuff and know
how to look up anything you don't quite
know how to do and understand what
that's the documentation you're looking
at talks about the next next part is
really just figuring out libraries and
figuring out kind of how to add stuff on
to your C++ and get additional headers
for what you want to do whether it be
graphical program or whether you're
gonna do programming forward or the
Unreal Engine as you can do all that
stuff and C++ so if you want to start
getting in STL but generally if you want
to do some graphical stuff you're gonna
need some add-ons to load in things as
building your own is gonna be really
complicated at first but getting those
libraries will help a lot and I've done
some tutorials on those in the past so
just let me know if you want to see
anything specific like that alright guys
I will see you some time in the future
with some new episodes until then peace
out keep on coding